[Music]
we're gonna move on to to Sam oh and and
after that we're gonna have a QA with
semo and Peter and so we'll make sure we
grab some stools we can grab them from
the bar for that part afterwards thank
you
welcome first off thank you Center this
is a wonderful opportunity for us to
think about the long-term future of the
world I've been doing research in the
area of you know institutional analysis
for about 10 years first seven years
quite academically last two years a
little bit more practical application
with my company Bismark analysis but my
true heart always lies and uh where
where might the future of our
civilization lie and how we can enhance
its prospects today's talk is going to
be on the overlap of institutions and
knowledge knowledge lives ultimately in
human heads but how it gets into those
human heads is the question that
education grapples with the question is
research grapples with the question that
social epistemic Commons have to grapple
with most of our universe is invisible
not literally we can infer that there
exists mass that is not detectable by
our telescopes and it's actually the
vast majority of mass physicists have a
term for this it's called dark matter we
know it exists because this is the
Andromeda galaxy galaxies are spinning
too fast to be held together only with
the visible matter that we can account
for so there's additional gravitational
force some something is pulling them all
in now maybe we have a flawed theory of
gravity but the current favorite
explanation is that there's a certain
kind of mass that we can't detect and a
lot of conventional sources of where
dark matter might be has been ruled
out you might naively think that you
know black holes are an obvious
candidate they don't actually amount to
enough mass to explain this phenomenon I
think there is an equivalent in
intellectual dark matter there are all
kinds of knowledge that are vital to the
operation of our society that are vital
to the creation of new knowledge that we
can prove exist but we cannot truly
easily access now there's question right
well obviously the person that has the
relevant knowledge must know it exists
that's an interesting question there's
like a problem of self-awareness that
philosophers have grappled with for a
long time is it possible to know that
you have you know is it possible to have
knowledge you don't know about I think
in a way there is right like you can
play basketball and not be able to
derive the physics of how exactly are
playing basketball and why the ball goes
into the hoop but you have this like
very embodied sense of how to handle how
to handle that ball a nice example of
intellectual dark matter is I think the
knowledge that existed in the past that
we perhaps still rely on that is no
longer here this is Greek text ancient
Greek for the vast majority of Greek
authors that we know by names so we know
they existed because they are referenced
in other works that are preserved they
are lost to us as actual thinkers they
only exist as references 13% of authors
from the ancient Greek world that we
know about have some fragment of text
preserved and only a little under 7
percent of them have a complete work
preserved so you might ask yourself well
if this stuff is lost you know how are
we relying on it and I'm going to draw a
straightforward path here where
institutions such as governments
companies religions education systems
clearly influenced by Greek philosophy
quite intentionally so both in the
Renaissance and you know with America's
Founding there were very big fanboys of
the Romans and the Greeks because they
were setting up a Republican system from
going out of a Mormon Arkell
implementation those thinkers
crafted their thoughts in dialogue with
these lost thinkers nine you know the 5%
a visible intellectual matter Plato
Socrates Aristotle you know
Pythagoras all of that stuff crafted in
the gravity well of the 90 to 93 percent
that we don't know about so how many
positions have we rediscovered in the
last few hundred years in the domain of
philosophy how much mathematics might
still be there you might disagree about
the relevance of say ancient Greek
mathematics and so on but you know
considered that recently maybe I should
go into this it's an interesting
technique right there was a in medieval
Europe parchment was scarce often monks
would scrape off text and rewrite new
text on top of it basically with modern
technology we can x-ray those pigments
and sort parchments my slovenian gets in
the way sometimes originally for
slovenia and detect that layer of
scraped off text because the ink
contained iron so because of that turns
out the ancient Greeks had something
quite close to calculus calculus was
only reinvented in the 18th century it's
a fun and interesting fact it was
reinvented in the 18th century both by
like Newton
maybe Gauss sort of you know maybe maybe
something there in Europe and in Japan
Japan also had its own completely
independent variant so we have three
independent origins in very different
societies where one exists in these sort
of like city-state context of the
ancient Mediterranean one exists on the
cusp of an industrial revolution one
exists in an isolation is too relatively
stable feudal structure that's basically
not trading with anyone that the last
one being Japan so I think it's not
beyond the scope of possibility that
there rose mathematics that we haven't
yet discovered that's in those 90% let
alone philosophy to move to a different
example of contemporary tacit knowledge
steel rests at the base of our
industrial supply chain so many of the
machines that we use in everyday life
perhaps are not made out of steel but
are manufactured in factories that
themselves use machines that have steel
as the key
making steel radically cheaper was a big
boost to both prosperity and engineering
because when you produce the material
artifact if there's no socio-economic
niche for it to live in if it's too
expensive it becomes a mere toy the best
example of this would be Heron steam
engine from ancient Alexandria it was
you know a simple steam engine it
transformed heat into motion
there was no application for it there
was no economic niche for it it was
something that existed within the
confines of a curiosity funded for the
sake of being a curiosity rather than
something like watt steam engine which
became useful and people wanted to copy
because they wanted to you know pump
water out of their coal mines and all
sorts of other applications over time so
the best immersed eel process in the
19th century made Steel radically
cheaper he developed a process and
patented it and then got sued by nearly
everyone to try to use the patent
because they couldn't make it work and
they called him a fraud well he tried to
explain it over and over and over again
how to do this how to do you know
revolutionize steel production making
all of us vastly wealthier and
indirectly not also vastly smarter and
he couldn't explain it so what he did
was raise capital built kind of his own
steel mill with partnership with some
people prove the process worked and you
know put a lot of those suing steel
mills out of business right so here we
had an example of knowledge that was
living in one person that was only
successfully transferred with that one
person built out the thing and then you
could have employees come to the steel
mill you could have engineers go look at
the steel mill and reproduce it it
wasn't possible to just have a
description a formal description of the
process so this is then the second kind
of intellectual dark-matter the first
one is knowledge that was lost that we
indirectly rely on that was used to
produce some of the knowledge we
currently still use and this other type
is this tacit knowledge that exists
everywhere again like a basketball
example right
our modern industrial supply chain is
very complicated even something as
simple as the processing of oil goes
through many steps from something like
you know what we draw at the ground to
what we perhaps use and distribute we
rely on this vast global network to
transport goods all over the planet some
technologies and some kinds of knowledge
live at scale I already talked about the
need to copy things right so there's the
kind of knowledge that can live in a
single lineage of student to teacher
Socrates Plato Aristotle there's the
kind of knowledge that lives in a steel
mill how to build you know a steel mill
that uses the Bessemer process it might
be only in 17 20 25 places around the
world maybe a hundred maybe 200
depending on which stage of the the
take-off you look at some technologies
require a global consumer market to be
viable you know some steam you know some
steam engines require hundreds of
millions of consumers if that network of
transport supply breaks down the
economic incentive Anish for the
technology to remain breaks down and
there's a nice historical example about
1100 BC you had you know actually 1200
BC you had a string of highly advanced
civilizations in the eastern
Mediterranean that were using C trade
which you know as everyone knows it's
much cheaper to transport materials
Goods and people over the sea than it is
to do so overland especially you know in
the in the age before for rail you had
the my seein Greeks yet the civilization
at Knossos you had the Hittites you had
the Assyrians you had the Egyptians in
about fifty to sixty years almost all of
those face severe collapse with Egypt
being essentially the only exception and
even the Egyptians ceased monumental
construction for about a hundred years
literacy was completely lost in the
Greek mainland for about three hundred
years they were illiterate after this
and
as we know it of classical Greece the
Greece of Socrates and so on that had to
be reinvented it was a true Greek Dark
Age some other parts of the Middle East
were a little bit luckier but in some
places we do not find pottery so there
are some regions where pottery has not
found the importance of this is that
pottery is the Neolithic technology and
when I talk to archaeologists they say
oh if we don't find pottery in a region
in the Neolithic we just assume it's
uninhabited because it's such a
ubiquitous technology it's something
that like every small tribe could make
for itself so the population collapse
apparently was so bad that in some
regions they were just completely
depopulated this is a beautiful
beautiful temple from Abu Simbel you
might know of this it's a unesco world
heritage site has an interesting story
history and when I was moved
that is a beautiful object that was
crafted just before this is monumental
architecture it has a lot of precise
features so that the light from the Sun
hits the statue of the relevant God at
exactly the right time it took years and
years to construct it happens in a
really remote location all down in the
south of Egypt almost in the border area
it was constructed by ramses ii right so
this is on the eve of that situation
here is like what's been termed
Agamemnon's mask another example of
wealth it's a golden mask found from my
scenes another example of a big trade
network breaking down and with it a loss
of knowledge actually let me go step
back the most important thing about this
breakdown is this is a civilization
powered by bronze bronze requires tin
and copper tin and copper tend to not be
find found in the same regions
the crucial thing that's lost is the
ability to produce bronze cheaply at
scale again consider steel right we have
steel they had bronze everything from
weapons to the tools used to carve out
carve this out of stone to the tools
used to like you know shape this this
golden mask and basically dig for the
golden or and so on all that is made out
of bronze so when that breaks down stay
no longer can field military's economic
productivity drops and all the
civilizations dissipate the red axis
there by the way are destroyed city
sites these are just places that burn
down in a period a little over 40 to 50
years yeah so you know ability to
provide security breaks down economic
productivity breaks down the society
started basically pillaging each other
as much as they could for the remaining
resources the next example of a you know
of a societal breakdown that leads to a
loss of technology as the Roman Empire I
hesitate to use the Roman Empire because
it's an example that's been overviews to
the course of our history everyone wants
to make it a morality play of some kind
everyone has their own interpretation
I'm going to make the argument that the
most significant feature of it is this
large trade network with wonderful
economies of scale where it's possible
to safely travel from one part of the
Mediterranean to another you now have an
integrated society over the whole
Mediterranean Basin both the East and
Western Mediterranean you have a lot of
indicators that this is a very wealthy
Society we'll look at those in just a
little bit but this artifact is one that
caught my attention when I first learned
about it it's the Lycurgus cup has
anyone here heard of this okay so we
have one person the Lycurgus cup was
donated by lourdes Rothschild to the
British Museum in the nineteenth century
it was discovered a few decades earlier
it has the nice property of being a
dichroic cup which means that shine
light from it from one end looks red
from the other end looks green they
didn't know how that worked
19th century engineers didn't know how
this worked and scholars had for about a
century or two before the cup was
discovered heard references and read
references actually where Romans are
writing letters to each other and they
saying oh you know Titus I received the
most marvelous gift I received this cup
the changes color depending on this you
know where I shine light on it
the conclusion of 18th century scholars
was that you know Titus after talking
about boring things like how many horses
to buy and like you know how some slaves
were misbehaving
became fanciful in that part of the
letter and was just making up an object
that obviously couldn't exist this when
it was found in the 19th century shown
to exist we only figured out how it
worked in the 1970s where a British
laboratory analyzed the glass and it
turned out that there is a precise
mixture of gold and silver particles
ground to the nanometer scale mixed into
the glass during the production process
after taking references seriously there
are hundreds of references to this
product which means that and actually
all over the Mediterranean world there
might have been only a single factory of
such objects but they shipped these
objects to Gaul - Hispania even to
britain and demand for such objects is
pretty neat it's like in a way a luxury
product so as soon as the economy
collapses as soon as the ability to sell
this thing to people that might be far
apart and people that are relatively
wealthy as soon as the pie of wealth
contracted this is no longer economical
and then a generation or two later no
one knows how to make such a thing we
have some measures and proxies for Roman
economic productivity that I think are
fairly reliable my favorite one is air
pollution you know today we might object
to the idea that we can use atmospheric
pollution as an indicator of
civilizational progress or prosperity
but Romans actually made it a fair
amount of lead into the atmosphere
atmospheric led from the Roman Empire
was captured in air bubbles in ice
forming in Greenland so as the ice was
forming in Greenland in the ice there
were air bubbles the air bubbles
captured a sample of the atmosphere at
that time today when we dig down into
the you know various ice cores in
Greenland we can have a fairly accurate
picture of the lead content of the
atmosphere throughout history and we see
something interesting the Roman Republic
has a productivity peak which is then
disrupted by the warfare of the lake
Republic with civil wars once a system
of pieces reestablished by you know
augustus economic growth goes back up
let production goes back up there are
various reasons to believe let
production correlates extremely well
with economic growth partially because
it correlates extremely well with how
many metals are they taking out of the
ground and that correlates with tools
weapons and all the other things we are
used to China has an interesting example
as well people don't realize how severe
some of their societal collapses have
been they always recovered but when we
say recovered what do we mean the most
severe one I think was the end of the
Han Dynasty where population crashes
over the course of 70 years by
two-thirds right so that period is
romanticized in a novel the romance of
the three kingdoms but it is or Matas
ation you wouldn't actually want to live
through that period the three kingdoms
being the big fragments that separated
from from the Han State 12th century
China is producing basically what we
would recognize as you know public
square city centre clocks you know
something very similar to what the
iconic image of London is today
accurately measuring time these clocks
were then not built four hundred years
later so in the Mongol dynasty and even
the munch Manchu dynasties later on they
no longer know how to build those there
are also some Chinese books that were
looted by the French and British in
their interventions in the 19th century
where the only preserved copy is the
looted copy right so in fact it was
possible that there were books being
lost even and even as recently as the
19th century part of the reason was
relatively closed you know political
system had tight control of a book
printing but part of it was there was no
good Suzhou economic niche for the mass
printing of books in Chinese society in
the nineteenth 18th century and it was
hardly unique in this regard there was
no such niche in the 13th or 14th
century in Europe let's now talk about
some modern examples to modern examples
and then I'll wrap up hopefully I'm not
too far over time Jade Jade is a
material that's quite important today we
use it in the next generation of censors
they're trying to
sorry the next generation of sensors
that will also be used to figure out
things about gravitational waves perhaps
knowledge that can resolve the puzzle of
dark matter
physical dark matter moscow laboratories
so laboratories in russia from moscow
state university had for about ten years
been finding radically different
measurements than their Western
counterparts measurements of the quality
of sapphire the quality factor called Q
on originally it's very important for
whether they're fit for these kinds of
applications or not what happened there
was a breakdown not of economics of
scale but of trust
Western laboratories stuck to their guns
basically accused the Russians of faking
their results the Russians reciprocity
said you guys don't know what you're
doing it took a physical visit from
Western researchers to Moscow State
University for them to be like oh
actually we don't know what we're
talking about the Russians had it
figured out we now know how to actually
get these measurements right the fun
part is the department that was doing
this research in Moscow State University
came dangerously close to being defunded
1990s Russia very chaotic not a lot of
funding for Sciences massive crash of
how many you know essentially weapons
researchers the new Soviet state was
willing to subsidize right a lot of the
civilian programs were ultimately
subsidized by military applications had
that been defunded before the visit of
Western scientists we might be decades
behind in the construction of those
sensitive sensors that I mentioned
earlier there is a danger in an
opportunity cost rather than a full-on
loss of knowledge of you lose the
concrete localized knowledge and
particular academic institution or
particular company and there's a larger
opportunity cost down the line that you
don't even realize that you're paying
right this was a story with a happy
ending which is why we know about it but
that's a notable selection affect CPU
production okay we talked about the need
for economies of scale we talked about
trust
we talked about political things maybe
getting in the way maybe working
currently Chinese doing extremely well
in replicating most relevant
technologies currently manufactured in
the Western world one area where they
lag our chip fabs chip fabs produce a
large amount of the basic information
infrastructure of our society day we all
rely extremely heavily on computerized
technology the best way to be robust
here would be to have not a few chip
fabs
but chip fabs distributed all over the
world and unfortunately there's an
economic disincentive to share knowledge
here I'm quite sure that if all the
Chinese experts unmask were invited to a
particular chip fab controlled by either
Western company or perhaps a Taiwanese
company or an Israeli company could
figure it out much as Western experts
invited to Moscow could figure out how
to make that happen but that's where the
coordination issues come in so okay for
a final thought I'm going to compare the
differences between a civilizational
collapse like two or three of the ones I
described in an intellectual Dark Age
one has a failure of critical systems
the other one also can have a failure of
critical systems over time one has loss
of relevant traditions of knowledge the
other one might also have a loss of
relevant traditions of knowledge but the
big differences here are in comparing
the destruction of capital today which
is very visible to the opportunity cost
of capital in the future you might not
know that you are missing extremely good
opportunities and that I think makes the
intellectual Dark Age problem much much
more serious okay thank you
[Applause]
can I ask you a question yes okay so
yeah I found that really interesting and
it's a couple points and at the end you
you sort of got to my question but I
want to expand a little bit what do we
know about you talked about the end of
the Bronze Age and I remember there was
a wonderful quote from the oil minister
of Saudi Arabia many years ago the UH
the iron the Stone Age didn't end with
the end of because they ran out of
stones right right and the oil age won't
win because we're gonna run out of oil
what do we know about really the kind of
unwinding of civilizations I remember a
talk about a year or so ago about the
Silk Road and the research would found
this ancient village that was part of
that infrastructure not far from where
the Chinese are building the port in the
middle of Kazakh stand right what do we
know about that ending that the
unwinding part of that
well we're facing severe epistemic
problems there because often you don't
have many written accounts that coincide
with you know the end of such a society
especially at a lower technological
level of development you might just lose
literacy as was the case in the Machine
Greek example causality is also
difficult always to tease out these are
interdependent systems and there are
many different hypotheses as to what
exactly is the linchpin is the linchpin
political something like you know their
ability to militarily secure the trade
routes is it perhaps like is the
linchpin something more economical or is
it something like we'll acknowledge and
so on I think the things we can solidly
know are basically things that have left
behind material artifacts I think this
is why I brought up the atmospheric lead
pollution
it seems pretty strong arguments that
that's a correlate we know how that
figure changed over time we also know
whether there are bronze artifacts lying
around in various parts of the eastern
Mediterranean as we know whether there
is pottery lying around and we can use
those proxies to adduce gauge what
coincides now teasing apart the Cazale
there's an interesting question here I
think this is you know almost more not
history but an integration of like
history and sociology where
I think a lot of the problems that
perhaps rise out of you know modern
approaches to economics or political
science or philosophy of science rests
in the fact that they disregard the vast
majority of the data set we have to
learn from can you imagine a discipline
of physics where we only admit the
experiments done in the last 10 years
you know that'll be a very strange kind
of physics but in political science and
economics and so on we often limit
results to the last 70 years or the last
hundred years
they're definitely phenomena that are
not going to show up in that short of a
time period so I mean is there a
discipline of collapse here somewhere I
mean how this all kind of unwinds it
just seems to be that's yeah wrote the
book collapse it feels to me there's
something very big in that question of
how things actually on y-you know was TS
Eliot captured it very well not with a
bang but with a whimper more
civilizations I think end with a whimper
than with a bang you know is it's
probably right I think that's quite
right at least for several examples the
Bronze Age one is actually a
counterexample it seems to end like
quite quickly forty to fifty years the
Roman Empire though if you want to think
about the fall of the Roman Empire it's
not literally barbarians but at the
gates burning things down it's imagined
GDP is shrinking every year for half a
percent for a hundred years at the end
you're vastly poorer the populations of
most large Roman cities through X cavae
ssin we can do estimates of a of their
population there's a wonderful paper on
estimating the change in the population
of Rome itself that perhaps all linked
or emailed to people we can tell that
population of those cities is shrinking
slowly we can tell that they're getting
poorer through the various correlates
that we have and it's imperceptible when
you read the letters of the people you
have when we read Roman letters you have
poets in the fourth century basically
saying ah you know Rome is fine things
are ok the roads are a little unsafe
lately and you know I'll visit you in
the spring like that's that's how the
literate class the elite class the
privileged class because the people who
are consuming literature were also the
senatorial class and the administrative
class so they do not know on an
institutional level what's happening to
them and that's why I said that you know
the sort of like the kind of
intellectual Dark Age question is very
interesting to me because you know if
all the intellectuals are gone who knows
that it's an intellectual Dark Age or if
all the technologists are gone who knows
it's a technological Dark Age right I
think it takes an expert to evaluate the
actual state of a relevant technology I
know that whenever you know I'm working
with someone and there's a technological
question the first thing I do is like
start hunting down and evaluating
experts and ask them for their opinion
because in a six month case study as I
might undertake I'm never gonna master
the technology I'm never gonna acquire
the tacit knowledge that's not even
explicate it so I have to rely on
someone else
I'm epistemic limited in that way I
remember standing in front of a Roman
aqueduct and looking at well how how did
this technology get lost yeah but I've
had the same reaction exactly I mean
people were standing there staring at it
for thousands of years it wasn't that
the technology really got lost it was
the security for men to end they passed
I mean it and so you know once once you
maintenance got lost well I think I
think it was more at the securing you
bring yourself throughout the security
part is if you have a water source and
the system that if anybody can just damn
it or poison it or do something bad to
it or some of it falls into disrepair
and no one's there it was really the
civilization that made that world safe
enough that water could travel safely
from one end of that wreck together it
wasn't people were standing there
staring at it because ears they knew it
worked that's an extremely good point
however I would just put a small counter
example to it when when Charlemagne
unites a large chunk of what today we
would consider France Germany and Italy
and tries to construct a beautiful
mausoleum for both his ancestors and
himself using Roman architecture looking
at the same beautiful buildings that are
still around it's miserable it
completely fails so it might take a
while to reinvent it but I strongly
agree with the idea that the physical
security that allows you to use such a
technology is vital for having there be
a niche where an architect might exist
or water engineer might
so I think this it is it is prior to
that knowledge so that's that's where I
would agree indiscreet
yeah that was either burned by
Christians or Muslims or whichever
whichever theory you you know by it
seems that media's destruction was much
more a lot of funding over generations
and then the library was not maintained
essentially ceased to exist as a that's
a living institution well I look we had
a similar situation with the space
program you know we've already lost
knowledge as we've cut funding for
various things we know less about how to
build big rockets today than we did 40
years ago example my father gave this
the 16-inch guns that were used on
battleships nobody could produce that in
this country now whether we need to is a
different story the point is the
technology no longer exists
is entropy affect knowledge it
straightforwardly seems yes yes you yeah
it does everything yeah but but
civilization is anti-entropic I mean
that is what civilization is in many
ways it is a measure of anti intra
entropy you know it's higher levels of
organization that persists
those
milord Alex lost but
things like the blockchain frankly
is that a centralized
these things there's a healthly
so that that that's if you're right and
I think there's something in what you're
just saying that what it implies that
one of the rules of long-term
civilizations is distributed knowledge I
not all concentrated in one big library
as it were and the capacity therefore to
recreate infinitely the Bronze Age
example all those people had bronze
technology well they had the technology
to use bronze but the supply chains that
allowed him to use that knowledge to
allowed him to use that technology broke
down so there was no reason to smell
bronze because you couldn't afford the
ten copper was cheaper but tin had to be
shipped from some really distant places
but the Phoenicians again like something
like 800 BC we're sailing all the way to
Britain to buy ten right and I think the
point about distribute technology is
completely correct in the last ten
thousand years when we look at your
Asian civilization it seems that
improvements in agriculture that don't
rely on infrastructure and improvements
in various localized metallurgy
something a blacksmith can do stick even
through civilizational collapses like
this there are some advancements that
are preserved right you know if you uh
if you import potatoes from the new
world and your civilization goes south
you're unlikely to use lose potatoes
because they literally have a DNA they
literally reproducing on their own and a
blacksmith that previously perhaps
worked on weapons for legionaries might
still find custom commissions with a
warlord or might manufacture jewelry to
support themselves they have a kind of
packet of knowledge that can live in
many many niches now the interesting
thing here though is like you know chip
fabs
they need huge economies of scale how do
you decentralize something that requires
economies of scale there's an
interesting contradiction in the
Industrial Age we can distribute the
products massively but we haven't really
distributed the means to produce the
products massively scale living at scale
it means you are centralizing things so
here's where I'm a little bit of a
contrarian I think Silicon Valley has
centralized rather than decentralized
societies so far on net even though
personal computers were amazing however
our information is
now processed in big computers perhaps
not too dissimilar from from mainframes
old and these servers these computers
are in jurisdictions of various
governments and I count the United
States and I count you appear as well if
you've traveled to Germany recently try
to access an American website you might
be under the impression that the German
government has gone to war with Internet
all that American sites are blocked
Google is paying massive and massive
fines for not complying with legislation
it seems to be targeted at US companies
right so there's there's an interesting
point there where the information is now
more and more being used as a tool of
political control the decentralization
of information seems to be like rolling
back a little bit because the physical
infrastructure in which it lives is kind
of centralized well you know that raises
an interesting question many of us I'll
put myself right there I suspect Stuart
and a few of us have been lamenting the
fragmentation of the internet right yes
the idea was we have this kind of global
system that everybody would access and
universal knowledge and collaboration on
a global scale etc and now we're getting
gonna have the Chinese internet the
European internet the American Internet
well maybe it's actually a good thing
not a bad thing right you know it may
increase robustness exactly and you know
so if the Chinese copy everything from
the West that may be a good thing you
know and I mean is proposing that like
link on a civilizational aspect is
extremely good for the Chinese to have
good chip fabs but on an economic
incentive landscape no current owner of
a chip fab once like someone else - yeah
but
the collapse of so was actually were
talking about before America mine
actually is a Greek food analysis
[Music]
so is this just ten yen's plague or
earlier okay
[Music]
history so does that is it is it an
implicit comment in what you're saying
that there are causes of collapse which
we have not paid adequate attention to
like for example disease outbreaks that
may be much more common than we imagined
and therefore more consequential in the
tale that we've ever imagined
yeah I think that's that's actually
extremely likely because for most of
history states don't know how to measure
population very well so even when we do
require written sources we could easily
miss a drop in population of 50 60 70 %
and then that impacts a lot of these
economies of scale that would then be
downstream of this like large population
with a with high spot rates of
specialization so the distribution of
disease whether that is digital disease
in the form of viruses or physical
disease in the form of viruses is may be
a really fundamental thing that we need
to understand as a long-term force
because it's not so hard to imagine how
that the digital version can unwind our
civilization pretty fast
yeah currently any sort of a cyber
warfare computer security expert just
throws up their hands and frustration
and they say we're you know we're [ __ ]
Catharine say
you sketch a lot of things to think
about about the evolution of
civilization
what I wanted to seed was basically
several topics I was not trying to I did
point to something like a concrete
synthesis but the synthesis is less
interesting than the facts I used where
hopefully other people that bring their
own expertise to the table can evaluate
some of the relevant points the ones I
want most thought about is how does
scaling affect the distribution of
knowledge how socio-economic niches seem
to be vital for the preservation of
particular technologies on this kind of
anthropological sense the number three
what kind of knowledge exists somewhere
in society that we might be relying on
that we might be subsidized by that is
not yet entered into our awareness that
we don't know about right where is what
is the Moscow State University research
project that we don't know about what
are some other examples like the chip
fab that potentially is like highly
centralized and it's perhaps similar to
an aqueduct right like you know global
piracy spikes up there's no more reasons
to build enough CPUs because the you
know the factory is no longer profitable
because you're no longer shipping chips
all over the world the chip fat closes
down and it's you know this kind of
whimper right I hope that answer the
question so these three these three
things are something I'm extremely
interested in talking about with
basically everyone here
it was also opinion of one was of
obstacle decline negatives continue
particularly thinking all sprouts how
generation
come to me baby
around the world and his pound of text
to accelerate some aspects of
multiplying
bring about the video
question somebody
but of course there are other kinds of
things we do on this one brings all that
help you
I think natural systems even complex
ones like ecosystems often go through
cyclical patterns I think it's quite
likely there's something not quite like
a cycle but perhaps a spiral it's a fact
that you know there seem to have not
been an immortal human society so far
they often seem to encounter pretty
severe problems as we can figure out to
evidence like population drops losses of
concrete technologies like to say the
Lycurgus cup and so on I do think most
of the cyclical theories have a problem
they want to be morality plays mm-hmm
they want to be morality plays they want
to tell us you know now we're rich and
now we're comfortable and now we're
decadent and immoral and we are too lazy
or something like this and that's a
problem the problem is it obscures the
real cycle the real cycles we might find
in history it miss attributes' them and
it gets they get a lot of attention they
overshadow it's sort of like the kind of
the popular notion of a cyclical view is
one where it's a matter of moral decay
now perhaps it actually is moral decay
but that would be like not trivial to
establish though make all sorts of
claims about anthropology right
economics and society and order have to
point that this factor is actually
upstream of all the other ones I think
other explanations
you know perhaps biological ones or
perhaps information flow ones or perhaps
economic structure ones are more
reasonable right obviously on a much
smaller scale than civilization collapse
in our current economic system we
observe this kind of cyclical pattern
right of like both cycles that you know
changed it in course of a business year
or cycles that are longer like 40 to 50
year technology driven cycles there's
also you know the fun question of
self-fulfilling prophecy where arguably
you know Moore's laws kind of no longer
relevant but for a while some people
proposed this is a fact about how the
technology must work and what I always
ask these people a few years ago was
well you know have you looked at the
rate of progress in Soviet development
of CPUs that didn't follow Moore's law
Moore's law was perhaps you know a
business plan that was implemented and
followed rather than a necessary
of how that technology would improve I'm
sure you have more commentary on that
well not on Moore's law but but III
think your point is well-taken and I
want to go back to another historian
we've had it long now a couple times
Neil Ferguson and Neil and I debated
this subject a few years ago and there's
there's another dimension to the kind of
alternate to the cyclical is the notion
of progress right that so if you read
Steven Pinker right Pinkner says yeah
we've made a lot of real progress if you
read Ferguson nah the progress is
ephemeral it is really a function of
who's in power at any given moment and
if we like it it's progress and if not
it's not and this progress thing is
really quite a very brief moment in
history we're back to normal
ie a struggle of the fittest and and in
a violent world I think there are
underlying models like cyclical like
progress like the lack you know the kind
of permanence of the human condition
Neil basically thinks human nature
doesn't change much that we aren't
really better people today than they
were a thousand years ago and as a
result we're gonna still do the same
stupid stuff they did a thousand years
ago when presented with the same
opportunities and so there's I think a
set of models that we paradigms if you
will of mental maps of how this
long-term change happens ie cycles
progress lack of progress that I think
want to be fundamental to our thought
process here I think that's that's very
true
following on that moral issue in
progress it seems to me that he
explicitly used the spork part that we
down Marty I would bet people a bet I
can't hear you
if you look at baseball the way that
they evaluated players in the first half
of the 20th century made certain people
look like stars who now with the new
psychoanalysis don't look like stars so
that we're not it seems to me I'm gonna
bring in Malcolm arguments book the
Aloni way about the Miwok Indians and
arguably the me was had a civilization
that was more viable more benevolent and
went extinct for obvious reasons
including air is coming in on top of
them but we're going from a premise that
there is a particularly aspirational
version of the civilization and the big
watts or another version of God matter I
kept I think the underlying possibility
of the fragility of whatever current
bubble that's that is the thing to focus
on where it's easy to be triumphant it's
easy to be complacent I think you know I
think Pinker does not really address in
his arguments the the dark matter that
is perhaps holding us together right and
an intentional study of this if this
were to become an academic field might
reveal things that are not only good you
know for our chances of survival or
helping us engineer more benevolent
societies but would just be perhaps like
profitable would be like a source of
prosperity I think often there's this
false dichotomy between prosperity and
robustness
I think we're nowhere near the
productive frontier of that I think we
could have a more prosperous
civilization that's also radically more
stable and radically more
environmentally friendly and you know
how to engineer that is a interesting
question you introduced an important
word that I think we'll want to come
back to fragility and we another long
now speaker Nassim Taleb talks now about
antifragility what are the mechanisms
that allow or institutions and systems
to be anti fragile because one of the
things we're wrestling
there is the mean walks are obviously
fragile in the sense of easily conquered
by the massive infusion from Europe
having said that there there's something
in here
around the idea of fragility that we
need to develop as well
is there any structural
factors
there was no Elon Musk on sage - well
that's an interesting question I think
often even if knowledge exists it's not
operationalized right for some reason or
another there you know human beings
experience a gap between knowing and
acting you know to reference some old
intellectual matter Plato says there is
no difference and if you knew well
enough the truth of the situation you
would always act I think this is
definitely not the case and I think you
know if you look at an individual like
Elon or like you know point to the real
I think very real role of particular
individuals especially in a founder
context because you know not just in
Silicon Valley but when we look through
history I mentioned Charlemagne a lot of
the peculiarities of those people shaped
the institutions that they created when
they set them up right like you know the
Catholic Church was earlier given as an
example perhaps not to emulate of a
long-lived institution but it's an
institution that came about as a because
a set of political decisions often
driven by individual ambition of various
Pope's and so on right so the overlap of
this kind of personal ambition this kind
of knowledge and this ability to act is
often the seed of new institutions why
there aren't more such people well
that's that's you know maybe maybe maybe
a biological question or a cultural
question or a philosophical question or
anthropological question it's one I
would very much want an answer to but
it's one I don't have an answer to just
those this session now before we have a
short break
Catherines question I'd love to get your
take on it about you've worked with
hundreds and thousands of large
institutions that were that's for some
reason coming to you because they were
probably at a moment of transition or in
some way curious about the future is
there something about those that you and
have seen that was common yeah
overwhelmingly crisis overwhelmingly
that is that people really say uh you
know we've we're in deep [ __ ] and we
don't know where we're going and we need
to figure out a better direction in one
way or another or we see a crisis coming
you know the resources gonna go away or
their technology's gonna change or
there's new competition coming off
overwhelmingly
they do not respond until they either
experienced or feel or see coming
imminently a crisis more often not it's
happened to them rather than they see it
coming and they say all right now we
need to think about the future right now
that is that the the most common
situation overwhelmingly
and was there something about some of
those institutions that you saw yeah the
ones who'd had previous crises sometimes
did better in the next one no I'm sure
no I'm quite serious that they learned
from look that's what she'll did not
figure out scenario planning because it
was more farsighted it because it [ __ ]
up and nearly killed the company in 1973
because it didn't see it had the
knowledge didn't pay attention and said
oops we could have done better in fact a
lot better and said all right now we'd
better get good at this so it was not
because they were farsighted is because
they learned from their crisis and
overwhelmingly that has been my
experience is that the organizations
that we worked most successfully with
with those tools had been through a
crisis and learned from it having
challenges we're not existential
whoa they have to be close to
existential right they have to recover
they have to you know go up to the edge
and look in the abyss and say oh my god
you know we need to find a better
solution here and that was
overwhelmingly the case companies that
and governments frankly you know that
that saw their situation in existential
terms look the best plant government of
the world is Singapore and because they
live in constant threat and fear of
their neighbors they say you know we're
tiny these guys could take us over in a
heartbeat
we'd better be economically robust
militarily strong powerful in a variety
of ways otherwise we're screwed and it's
not because they think generously about
the future and the long term it's
because they're scared and so that
really overwhelmingly has been the
motivation fear another another relevant
example of this might be the strong
success of Rwanda in recent years where
it's the fastest-growing African economy
you guys might still remember from the
1990s genocide Paul Kagame the current
president Rwanda who is explicitly cited
Singapore as the desired model of
development and in fact the country has
been experiencing rapid economic
development and stability and you know
lack of political conflict even
something like a national reconciliation
between the Hutus and the Tutsis which
were the two ethnic groups during the
genocide he starts off as the commander
of military forces from the outside of
Rwanda are this really ragtag group of
Tutsis trying to intervene to stop the
genocide in various ways in various
various places that's where they
developed a lot of the relevant
organizational skill that's where they
basically trained the next military and
the next crop of competent people that
then come in and are helping to govern
the country well so that's another case
of like crisis learning Stuart
an existential crisis thing really
fascinates me because you're pointing
out that having really had one or two as
an organization alerts you to the future
once we take them seriously and possibly
try to work around them but all this
anticipation of existential crises seems
to have the opposite effect hey your
arms are going to kill us
climate change is gonna kill us
everything's gonna go I just think these
things are grossly exaggerated and since
we want that motivation so the terror
that will make us learn but be it's
[ __ ] if it's just anticipatory it
doesn't have the effect you're talking
about instead of deadening see what are
we talking about here but isn't this
part partly
immune response right where it's where
you you tell that story about the future
you we have evidence like Pinker's
evidence over things have always been
getting better walking with very short
exceptions in time you're playing some
things like that but we still most of
our science fiction right now is very
very non utopian totally and so like why
is that is that a way that civilization
is telling itself a story so it can make
sure that that story doesn't happen
that's one version I think the other
version is
that is so unreal and it's so keeps not
happening this is one of the things that
live a long time
I grew up nuclear with nuclear
Armageddon and then there's one that you
are getting at remember the energy
crisis eat breakfast we all thought that
was the end of everything I actually
said it out loud in front of audiences
desperately stupidly we're about five
years ago people
yeah like that good old people or y2k
these come on and it's teaching us too
we devalue yeah exactly
why we should declare a national
emergency why don't we do that I think
that's a brilliant idea it might
motivate some change
[Music]
well if I may talk about that briefly I
think the manufactured crises can in
fact be used to terraform parts of
society change it in various ways and it
can be very effective in that
however the manufactured crises is a
controlled experience for you know
Comrade Stalin or comrade Mao or whoever
else and for them the manufactured
crisis is not challenging their thinking
it would take a genuine crisis to have
those people be challenged and have them
grow so you know yes I think it is an
effective tool of social engineering and
when I say social engineering I'm like
I'm all in favor of good social
engineering over all right I feel I feel
there are many things about society we
might want to reengineer but I don't
think it solves the problem at the very
top level
I have to apologize that I have to run
out for about an hour so I have to go
help sure the long-term survival of the
company I work for
[Applause]
[Music]